coming into season two there is a lot
happening uh Lola did you know where you
were going to go in this season and how
you were going to end up you know I know
you guys have started filming uh season
three already so you kind of know her
future past that or when you have it no
we don't we don't need to know what's
happening with that unless you know
something
I was just doing some Googling
did but did where uh season two go
surprise you
um uh I guess
yes and no I think we kind of had the
the blueprint of the book which
um you know Jenny is such a so dedicated
to
um staying true to her work and just
making like bringing that Vision to life
while keeping the heart of the book and
I think
um it was really special to have that so
I kind of knew in that sense but also I
think
there were so many
um there were so many new things and
added added uh
like like just her relationships with
the boys are slightly different than
they are in the books especially coming
off of season one
um
so I kind of feel like
yes we kind of had most of the scripts
at the beginning but you never really I
don't know it's it's all kind of a
journey with the character so you I feel
like you never really know where where
you'll end up um and it was really fun
to to go on that Journey as with belly
and with you I mean you can also like
you can even do as much work as you want
on a script beforehand it it all kind of
changes the moment you step into the
space and actually start doing it you
know yeah yeah I mean Sean this season
you have a whole new romance that was
kind of hinted at last season with
Lorraine's character Taylor
um how do you think Sean has uh how do
you think not Sean you're good your hair
grows grown from his previous
relationship with Shayla yeah and does
that growth translate to his
relationship with Taylor I think so I
think uh
if anything
um Susanna's death has kind of shown
that
there's a lot of stuff from the past
that he needs to look at he needs to
take a second to look around who's
really kind of been there
um all his life and his who's been next
to him and I think such a shocking event
uh kind of
brings everything back to reality and he
looks to his side and
sees a person that has been with him for
the whole time and so I think he's
learned a lot from his relationship with
Shayla I don't think he forgets it I
don't think he uh pushes it to the side
but I think he also understands that
to make amends and to have a good
relationship with somebody else you must
learn from your past and you must
acknowledge it you know
obviously
um everyone in the show is dealing with
the loss of Susanna in their own way but
I think it's
um I wish that we had more of belly and
Steven's reaction because they obviously
they grew up with Susanna
um and saw her every summer but how do
you think her death affected them um and
did you how did you um process that and
Lola I'll start with you for that one
you know I think
in their family
um and this is sort of Laurel's battle
throughout the season but it seems like
for the most part they sort of deal with
things on their own and they have
trouble kind of coming together and and
grieving together
um
and so I think
especially at the beginning of the
season
um
belly was really living in that in her
own world her own headspace not really
wanting to interact with anyone else and
not feeling like anyone else could
really understand her experience because
I don't think Steven ever reached out
and said hey I understand that
experience and I don't think Laura will
ever reached out and said hey I
understand that because they were all
trying to sort of be strong for each
other
um and to move forward in their own ways
and I think it's really beautiful to see
Stephen and belly a little bit later
into the season maybe like episode three
or four when Stephen gets to the summer
house and belly just says to him like
I'm glad you're here they do need each
other and they do lean on each other
even if it's in smaller ways like that
um it's important to be there for each
other and I think they both need that
yeah even when they don't show it you
know just it's that small like one word
thing yeah yeah
for sure I mean so I'm asking this
question to everybody and I'm curious to
hear your guys's answer
um who do you guys think you personally
not your characters uh think that belly
should end up
yeah
Sean is uh very hard
to distinguish from Stephen sometimes uh
being an older brother myself so Sean is
always and will be team belly which I
know ain't the answer people want to
hear but I as an older brother just want
like my little sis to be happy
like and whoever that is whether it's
nobody or somebody I just want you to be
happy
I feel like as cast members like as
characters it's much
like harder to be like you should be
with this boy you should be with that
boy especially because we do see so much
of belly's inner battle and like how
much she goes back and forth because
there's not like a you know
one perfect person all the time it's
it's messy and that's life and
um so I think I think it makes sense to
be team belly and to to ultimately be
like you know what
follow your heart follow your heart see
where it takes you you're young you got
time as I'm like three years old
um but yeah yeah team Valley yeah I mean
I agree 100 I like that Laurel was like
I want you to have many lovers yeah
I agree
um thank you so much for speaking with
um I really like this season I thought
it was a great uh great follow-up to the
first season and I can't wait to see
where you guys go in the future uh yeah
thank you so much thank you thank you